cette image est devenu habituel depuis
le début du confinement imposée par le
gouvernement face au coc u19
on croise encore plus de joggeurs autour
de la pièce d'eau des suisses à
versailles
sous un soleil printanier ce coureur
occasionnel a rempli son attestation
pour venir s'oxygéner pendant une
trentaine de minutes
ouais ça fait devient presque surtout
j'habite dans sto lieu de 15 mètres
carrés du coup rester confinés comme ça
ça fait dix jours que j'ai pas sorti en
plus j'ai vu sur la télé il y avait un
médecin qui a dit s est pas bon de
rester confinés comme ça il faut courir
présentant ses importants pour le
système immunitaire aussi pour les
runner plus confirmés ce confinement
prend une autre tournure
c'est dit diallo 65 ans est un habitué
des marathons des épreuves qui courent
pieds nus à travers le monde
lenny monthey a vu son planning de ces
prochains mois chamboulé suite aux
différentes décisions gouvernementales
ce moment si je devais être en route
vers l'aéroport de roissy pour courir le
marathon de séoul le 22 mars dimanche
ensuite c'est et aux roms annulé après
c'était paris annulé marseille annulés
et ainsi de suite c'était toutes les
semaines pour continuer à pratiquer sa
passion le sportif toujours équipé de
son autorisation court pieds nus à
proximité de son domicile tout en
prenant toutes les précautions pas
nécessairement tous les jours mais mais
c'est vrai que ici et pas de monde on
peut inviter les gens qu'on rencontre et
ce cadre là et est parfait pour sentir
pratiquer la course à pied avec ou sans
chaussures le gouvernement autorise les
joggeurs munis de leur autorisation à
réaliser leur séant seul à proximité de
leur domicile
500 mètres en ville deux ou trois
kilomètres si on habite en campagne